depuis octobre pascal lecourt entre
produits avec quatre autres éleveurs un
lait d'une nouvelle marque pure perche
sa particularité être produit au coeur
du parc naturel du perche et suivre un
cahier des charges précis à calais les
charges pour adhérer pur perche c'est
déjà d'avoir des vaches qui pâturent au
moins six mois de l'année
dans désherbage comme celui ci derrière
moi et puis et puis d'avoir un minimum
de surface c'est à dire 25 hectares de
pâturages pour un troupeau de maximum
sans tête
l'objectif bien nourrir les animaux en
veillant à préserver les prairies
aujourd'hui les vaches ne sortent pas à
cause de la pluie mais l'exploitant
assurent leur donner des aliments sans
ogm et sans soja pour produire un dessin
un lait vendu directement aux
supermarchés sans passer par une
coopérative le but essayer de vivre de
son travail à la circulation avant était
on travaille avec un industriel avec un
contrat il y avait une certaine forme de
monopole
ce qui fait qu'on était lié avec
l'industriel et c'était rémunérés de
façon inférieur aux coûts de production
là on est rémunéré au dessus des coûts
de production donc pas ce qui fait que
c'est
c'est viable pour l'avenir et le projet
pure perche séduit car ce lait local est
déjà présent dans une dizaine
d'enseignants nre et loire comme
intermarché hyper u leclerc un plus pour
les consommateurs c'est
locales déjà premièrement si juste à
côté puis faire travailler des
agriculteurs pourquoi pas
il y en a tiré on va dire de proximité
proposer un produit que les
consommateurs puissent gérer connaître
ce que je suis j'irai habitant de char
je connais le perche
donc je suis rassuré il ya une espèce de
désir et de relation directe entre le
produit et le consommateur
cinq autres enseignes d'eure-et-loir
devrait commercialiser ce lait d'ici peu